la domanda nella posta innanzi tutto è
dx perché fino ad ora non avevo mai
considerato propriamente attivista c'è
un dato oggettivo sono impegnate in atto
nell ormai da quasi una decina di anni
quindi quando ho ricevuto questi dito
per prima cosa mi sono chiesta ma in che
senso sono ottimista che cosa significa
fermati e le risposte la trovate per
l'appunto di questa organizzazione
straordinaria internazionale della quale
ho potuto partecipare ci sono due
ragioni sostanzialmente per le quali mi
riconosco in azione per sé alcune riesco
poi a considerarmi acquisto
la prima ragione riguarda una
trasformazione straordinaria che a mio
avviso progredire sordina e propria
davvero una rivoluzione culturale in
questo settore che actionaid ha fatto
tradizionalmente delle nasche accende
come un affare che come se ne sono molte
altre
nasce a londra raccoglie folli nel nord
del mondo e usa questi soldi per fruire
perché servizi alle comunità povere ed
escludere emarginate nel sud del mondo
questa immagini che potete vedere per
l'appunto rappresenta questo approccio
molto tradizionale ma certo punto al sun
e si è resa conto che questo tipo di
approccio era inefficace
c'era la necessità di aprirsi mettersi
in ascolto di quelle persone che si
voleva per l'appunto aiutare che c'era
qualcosa di paternalistico da pensare da
londra fosse possibile decidere cosa
fosse bisogno appunto ad eni in africa
nell'america latina dove pure
un'organizzazione per oggi azione ed è
alla federazione in ogni paese in cui
siamo presenti
ci siamo dotati culture con il locale e
sono stato io ci stiamo dotando di una
struttura di governance quindi una idea
ed un consiglio composto da persone che
vivono in quello stesso paese
i rappresentanti di ciascun paese
confluiscono poi in un'assemblea
internazionale
e concorrono insieme a decidere quali
siano le tonalità quali siano le
strategie quali gli strumenti migliori
per perseguire la missione di ghiaccio
lire ovvero appunto come dicevo
combattere la povertà e l'esclusione
sociale
oggi actionaid e questo perché immagine
è stata trattata a johannesburg ha visto
di quest'anno 120 persone che
provenivano da tutto il mondo hanno
insieme posto le basi per quella che
sarà la nuova strategia di azione per i
prossimi cinque anni
per me individualmente
la cosa fondamentale che ho imparato
nella quale mi riconosco è il fatto che
ci si deve aprire all'esperienza del
guardian concezione del mondo e ai
bisogni delle altre persone che da soli
si da poco si va poco lontano
c'è una seconda un secondo insegnamento
generale che ho appreso da sé che
riguarda i valori
il fatto che abbiamo bisogno di valori
che siano in qualche modo che ci
tratteniamo che trascendano nostri i
nostri interessi particolari sembra una
banalità ma riuscirà a sentire a
costituire questa cosa che ovviamente a
metterlo in pratica e alimentare a tutti
i giorni quello che sono particolarmente
importanti
a questo mi vorrebbero restare un
filosofo israeliano che si chiama a
richard margalit diciamo direttamente
strutturale via colette ma credo che sia
particolarmente pertinente margalit è
entrato un po di anni fa individuo che
si chiama la società deferite un
dibattito molto classico della filosofia
che è quello della società giusta e
questo aiuta e magali che cos'è una
società giusta e regista è praticamente
impossibile definire in maniera efficace
molto meglio suggerisce malgrado cercare
di proporsi di costruire una società
decente è una società di cento invece
stranamente o dissenso site
è una società che non umilia i propri
cittadini ecco io credo che questo sia
un utilizzo strumento efficace molto
tagliente per orientare le politiche
pubbliche anche e tutto sommato i nostri
comportamenti individuali bracciate
questo sanno dire che si è tradotto nel
trasformare profondamente il proprio
modo di operare che se un tempo ed
andava come fanno molte organizzazioni
in parte minima parte ancora il caso di
grande emergenza tanto ragione di tanta
azione a fornire beni e servizi dove
c'era bisogno per altri beni e servizi
questa visione oggi ha superato questo
modo perché ci si è resi conto che così
facendo si andava a leggere a
interferire con quello che dovrebbe
essere un rapporto stretto un patto tra
cittadinanza e le istituzioni
al contrario ogm e cerca di lavorare
soprattutto di fare leva soprattutto su
due
da un lato i diritti delle persone
promozione dei diritti
dall'altro la cantabilità
che si che significa poi completamente
la costruzione di regole in maniera
partecipata trasparente il rispetto di
queste regole l'impegno a rendere conto
del proprio operato oggi per altro
account di ripiego più al centro della
nuova strategia d italia che è stato da
poco lanciata in parallelo con quella
internazionale
ma oggi vi volevo parlare per l'appunto
anche dell'italia di quello che io sento
essere davvero un urgenza molto forte
nostra e questo riguarda quella che a
mio avviso è e non è soltanto una
percezione mia ma è una progressiva
frammentazione molto marcata
nella nostra società in cui ci si si si
contrasta sì sì sì confligge
costantemente ci si contrappone senza
che vi sia modo di trovare uno spazio in
cui trovarci discutere e costruire
insieme abbiamo conflitti a livello
politico di cui inutile di tel aviv l
altro abbiamo conflitti a livello
generazionale
abbiamo colpiti a livello interessi
diversi e abbiamo completamente perso di
vista il fatto che abbiamo bisogno
invece di un terreno comune da impartire
vorrei fare notare che in tutto questo
c'è un ulteriore elemento che secondo me
oggi rende la situazione ancora più
problematica più difficile e che
riguarda il modo in cui noi ci
informiamo i luoghi dove noi
prioritariamente andiamo a cercare le
informazioni
questo modo pino jodice informiamo il
nodo è la quantità straordinaria di
formazione di cui possiamo disporre oggi
fa sì che ciascuno di noi
molti di quanto il passato si costruisca
un proprio background culturale e che
sia molto difficile per rintracciare una
sorta di base comune culturale tra noi
italiani inter e funzioni è una grande
ricchezza una straordinaria risorsa
però dobbiamo comunque forse problema di
dove troveremo i fondamenti per il
territorio e comunità del linguaggio
comune considerato che tutto che i
luoghi dove comunitariamente non certo
che anche con internet internet o di
sempre vicini anche questi territori
oggi troviamo dei meccanismi che in
maniera molto subdola senza che noi ce
ne accorgiamo favoriscano questa
frammentazione
se prendete facebook del fb il maniero e
tanti altri colossi della gestione
dell'informazione
quello che sta succedendo anche questi
soggetti stanno filtrando l'informazione
in modo tale da personalizzare essere
più efficienti del modo in cui ci
forniscono informazioni personalizzate
informazione geografica che vi verrà
fornita informazioni che vi corrisponde
tv somiglia sempre di più è che tutto
quello che è diverso da voi rischia di
finire fuori dal nostro campo visivo non
l'ho percepito e non ne siete neppure
consapevoli
questo contribuisce potenzialmente a una
spinta verso la pressione di isole di
persone che si ritrovano si conoscono e
che però hanno poco poca contezza di
quello che c'è al di fuori di loro
penso quindi che abbiamo un grandissimo
bisogno di inventarci di trovare dei
nuovi luoghi comuni
usiamo questo questa espressione che di
solito viene piegata del 2000 al
pressante nuovi nuovi comuni quali
possono quali possono essere e che cosa
devono essere un devono essere dei buoni
in cui ciascuno di noi si senta a
proprio agio ad esporre quello che è a
manifestare le parole propria identità e
previsioni sui propri punti di vista ma
questo non è sufficiente deve esserci
anche una disponibilità all'ascolto
un'apertura e una curiosità nei
confronti di quello che c'è d'altro e di
diverso dal solito
quando la scuola ha avuto l'insegnante
molto brillante in austriaco che aveva
l'abitudine segnava etica e aveva
l'abitudine di dividere la classe mista
prendere un tema livello attraverso e di
dire a una parte della classe di
sostenere con una determinate tesi e
all'altra metà della classe di sostenere
la chiosa tramite posta
questo a prescindere completamente a
prescindere dalle dalle preferenze
individuali
in questo modo ciascuno di noi era
portato era costretto in qualche modo a
distaccarsi almeno momentaneamente dal
proprio credenti nelle proprie
preferenze a prendere sul serio gli
argomenti che erano sul tavolo
credo che ci sia un grandissimo bisogno
di questo tipo di esercizio
c'è bisogno di questo esercizio nelle
scuole ma probabilmente anche fuori e mi
chiedevo se non fosse pensabile
immaginare una sorta di piattaforma su
internet che internet nonostante quello
che mette fota rimane nuovo in cui
costruiamo tutti il cui le informazioni
nel cercare ci sono una piattaforma in
cui fosse possibile ri raccontarci e
disegnare il paese italia così come la
vorremmo se vogliamo fino ad arrivare
quasi a ridefinire a ricostruire passo
per passo una sorta di costituzione
italiana fatta in maniera però del tutto
partecipato
è un'idea assolutamente libri onale il
momento che ho voluto oggi condividere
con voi che ha personalmente mi sembra
utile e interessante in qualche modo a
complemento del mio impegno in alto nel
oggi alcune tutto è impegnato
soprattutto in italia sui temi della
cantabilità ma avendo ben presente che
c'è una necessità di riportare maggiore
consapevolezza sui valori di costruzione
della percezione di quanto importante
sia avere un terreno comune nel quale ci
si riconosca tenuta insieme da valori
comuni
in questo gioco che per il momento è
pura speculazione mi piacerebbe poter
coinvolgere le scuole mi piacerebbe
poter partire dai bambini delle scuole
chiederanno che tipo di paese vorrebbero
che fosse l'italia
e chiedere poi ai ragazzi po più grande
di prendere queste idee di elaborarle di
affinarle così andando progressivamente
a generare da un lato una banca dati di
materiali di speculazione di immaginario
un'esperienza diffusa molte persone
quante più persone possibile il
confronto appunto con persone altri da
sé è progressivamente usando
procedimento degli strumenti che quelli
di chi ci ha parlato questa mattina gli
ospiti provando abbracciare di nuovo
ad affinare insomma tutto questo
materiale ea tracciare dei valori nei
quali ci si possa riconoscere danno
parte e delle regole dei nodi poi per
tradurre questi valori nella realtà un
gioco del tutto speculativo che provo
tempismo che penso possa essere fatto in
rete più difficilmente in altri ambiti
perché abbiamo bisogno di trovare un
territorio neutro per quale sia davvero
la confidenza per svestiti
contemporaneamente dei propri interessi
personali e per esporsi senza sentirne
di rischio del conflitto con l'altro è
visto di essere subito aggrediti come
tutto 800 si spesso succede questo era
il piccolo progetto alla piccola
speculazione per le chiese volevo
condividere con voi oggi
forse il messaggio che preme di più a
lasciare è quello immaginiamo dei luoghi
comuni
credo che questo sia davvero urgente per
tutti noi
i modi possono essere tanti e credo che
ciascuno di noi possa provare nel
proprio nella propria sfera privata
abrogando sul negoziato persone delle
declinazioni